Paid social marketing is another way to
get your product in front of valuable
customers.
Now you're probably already using social
media to engage with the community for
free, but when you want to drive
customer acquisition directly,
you can consider buying paid
marketing on social media.
LinkedIn, Facebook, Twitter, Instagram,
Snapchat, StumbleUpon, Pinterest
are all among some of the biggest names
in paid social marketing right now.
Now there are few things you
should think about when paying for
social media marketing.
First, you need to understand
how the different ads are sold
because each network
does it differently.
For example, LinkedIn and Facebook
will have you pay by impression.
On the other hand, Twitter is going to
have you pay based on engagements.
Second, optimize the design
of your ad for smartphones.
Social media is overwhelmingly
consumed on mobile devices.
Over half of Facebook users visit
the site on a mobile device, and
Twitter users spend 80% of their
time on the mobile devices.
So you want to keep that in
mind with your messaging.
Your ad should be short and
to the point.
Your ads should also link directly
to the mobile landing page or
directly to the app you
want them to download.
And the settings should be aligned
to different mobile platforms you’re
aiming for.
And third, have some fun with it.
Explore with the different
platforms they let you do.
For example,
Twitter will let you pay for
tweets that are targeted by ZIP code.
On the other hand, Snapchat let's
you sponsor selfies like this one.
So let's hear from the social
media marketing expert.
>> My name is Chris Morell and
I worked in social media marketing and
content marketing for
the last ten years or so for
brands including Fitbit, Clif Bar, Sony
PlayStation, and now here at Udacity.
When you're thinking about
starting with social media,
there's some really important
things to consider.
I think first and foremost,
know your audience.
I can't stress that enough.
Go and do research on your
audiences on each social platform.
Dig into analytics.
Dig into Twitter analytics,
Facebook analytics,
anything you can to get a really
good sense of your audience.
Make sure you're constantly listening
to what your audience is saying.
This will give you a really great
perception of your audience and
exactly who you're trying to
market to with paid social.
The target audiences for
each social channel are going to vary.
And I think the more that your app or
product develops and
the more time you spend in each channel,
you're going to realize that each
audience has its different,
unique characteristics.
For example, Twitter might be really
great for customer support and
Instagram and Pinterest might be great
for sharing organic photo assets,
brand images and just really great,
engaging content.
It's important to really
know your demographics.
Do some research, use free tools, use
anything at your disposal to discover
age, gender and any important
demographic info that you think is
going to help create a better and
more successful ad campaign.
When you start setting up campaigns
you're also going to notice that the big
platforms Facebook, Twitter and
LinkedIn, they're really competitive.
Something to consider if you
want to stay ahead of the curve
is to advertise on emerging channels.
So think Instagram and
Pinterest, think Snapchat.
These aren't going to be as competitive
as channels like Twitter, Facebook,
LinkedIn and
you might get better returns.
Success on channels like Instagram and
Pinterest might be as simple as creating
experiences and
ads that feel real to the user.
They feel like organic posts from
our brand, and not an advertisement.